finlandia y suecia están cada vez más
cerca de convertirse en miembros de la
otan porque tras más de cuatro horas de
negociaciones en extreme es aquí en
madrid finalmente turquía ha levantado
su veto para que los dos países nórdicos
puedan entrar en la alianza en el
acuerdo suecia y finlandia se han
comprometido a cambiar su legislación
antiterrorista y también a tener un
acuerdo de extradición sobre todo de
miembros del pkk de el partido
nacionalista acuerdo que el gobierno
turco considera una organización
terrorista al veto de turquía se ha
hecho muy de resistir tan durante más de
un mes el gobierno turco ha evitado que
los dos países nórdicos puedan
convertirse en miembros de la alianza
para poder empezar las negociaciones
para poder entrar en la otan por sus
reservas porque considera que estos
países nórdicos protegían a miembros del
pkk ahora con esta luz verde podrá
empezar el proceso a partir de mañana
todos los miembros de la alianza
dar luz verde a que estos dos países
puedan convertirse en miembros de la
otan tras ello se convertirán en países
invitados de la alianza pero podrán
participar en las reuniones y tras ello
habrá un proceso de ratificación para
que oficialmente ya suiza y finlandia
puedan convertirse en estados miembros
se trata de una decisión histórica que
acaba con una decisión con una política
de finlandia y suecia de total
neutralidad ha acabado con decenas de
años de neutralidad una señal más que la
invasión de ucrania por parte de rusia
ha cambiado para siempre el mundo